on this monday night russia increasingly
isolated but still attacking ukraine
the ceasefire talks and the sanctions
suffocating the russian economy well you
don't want
a madman backed into a corner with
nothing to lose plus the mounting
desperation of those fleeing
and how the sanctions aimed at russia
could impact canadian wallets from actor
and comedian to commander-in-chief
the leadership and bravery of ukraine's
wartime president and people on the
planet are getting clobbered by climate
change
the warning about irreversible impacts
of global warming
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are following multiple threads on the
war in ukraine tonight as russia looks
increasingly isolated for the first time
since russia invaded talks took place
between ukraine and russia on a
ceasefire but there was no breakthrough
and nothing has stopped
this is ukraine's second largest city
harkeef ukraine says dozens of people
have been killed by russian missile
strikes though the city is not believed
to have fallen into russian control it
is very difficult to get an accurate
picture of what's happening on the
ground uk defense intelligence says
there have been multiple russian strikes
inside the country but the bulk of
russian ground forces remain more than
30 kilometers north of kiev their
advance slowed by ukrainian forces
defending an airfield
associated press reporter joe fetterman
is in the ukraine capital for us again
joe i know
people were able to emerge from shelters
and basements earlier today but the air
raid sirens have started again and i
guess the people of kiev face another
night under russian attack
that's what it looks like we did have a
lull as you said we emerged from a
curfew this morning
some people were out the streets were
still very deserted people are only
running out for essentials and getting
back
back home and then as evening arrived
it's been one air raid siren after
another i think we've had four or five
of them this evening even more ominously
though
satellite footage is showing a massive
russian military convoy making its way
toward the city they estimate its length
at about
17 miles long of equipment tanks and so
forth supplies so all indications are
the russians are closing in on the city
yeah those satellite images are
are chilling
how daunting is it for people
in the capital city tonight
yeah i think uh what you have seen in
recent days i think you see a lot of
national pride here uh the city has
remained quiet because the uh ukrainian
military has so far been able to fend
off uh the the invading russian forces
uh so spirits uh on one hand it's very
quiet but it's also very tense and you
just have to wonder how long can they
keep this going they've done a good job
so far but it just seems like the
russian forces are going to
become overwhelming at some point joe i
know it was difficult to get around the
city over the weekend because there's a
curfew in place i know it's incredibly
dangerous to do so now can you give us
any sense though of the rush of the
ukrainian defenses around the city of
kiev
that is tough to say uh not only because
it's hard for us to move but even when
you see things they don't want you
reporting it in fact you can get into
trouble because they think that you're
giving away military secrets so it's
very hard to get a gauge
on that uh you know all we can say is uh
not only uh here in the in the capital
but in other cities we just see fierce
resistance you see a very determined
army it may be
undermanned but
morale appears to be high the
determination appears to be high and in
every location they're putting up quite
the fight all right joe fetterman from
the associated press in the ukrainian
capital tonight thanks joe
thank you
ukrainian resistance is standing strong
the ministry of defense they're tweeting
instructions for how to make and aim
molotov cocktails it says the end of the
war is in the hands of each of us and
russian state tv showed vladimir putin
meeting with his top officials he has
ordered his nuclear forces onto special
alert the head prosecutor of the
international criminal court announced
today he's opening an investigation into
the situation in ukraine saying there is
a reasonable basis to believe that both
alleged war crimes and crimes against
humanity have been committed crystal
gomencing is reporting tonight from
poland
the russian assault is not relenting in
ukraine
more missiles pounding parki this video
captured by residents watching the
onslaught just outside of ukraine's
second largest city images surfacing of
a school destroyed following a firefight
similar sites in kiev russian forces now
surrounding the city on multiple fronts
but so far the ukrainian military has
dug in
holding the capital
a presidential adviser warning russian
forces quote you will be drowned in the
offensive your command is using you as
meat
thousands of residents have little
choice but to flee so many are
scrambling to try and get to poland that
the route is now flooded
some must change course on the fly
this man says he spent three days
attempting to enter poland with his
family before heading to romania where
they are now finally safe
very difficult station
for people we were just driving and
crying because
seeing how people desperate
it's just impossible for those who
manage to make it across the polish
border this is what awaits them a
makeshift camp near the medica crossing
it's one of many organizers here are
seeing about 2 000 people arriving daily
this mother left ukraine with her three
young children they were picked up by a
bus for moms with kids
while there is fear and stress
julia expresses gratitude
thank you to the volunteers who provided
my children with tea poured soup
sandwich during our drive
unicef reports hospitals schools even
orphanages are coming under fire
children cannot truly escape this war
but what if you don't have a family
heidi baumbach flew from alberta to
poland she'll soon be on the road
helping to shuttle children from an
orphanage to safety having another
vehicle and another driver there might
mean that another car load of kids makes
it out those who were unable or
unwilling to flee
now hide and wait
as the fighting continues in ukraine
more facilities like this will be needed
the united nations estimates more than
500 000 people have already fled ukraine
that number will keep rising
donna crystal commencing in poland
thanks vladimir putin is accused not
just of waging an unprovoked war on
ukraine but of threatening the peace and
security of the world russia is
increasingly isolated its banks are cut
off its airlines banned from western
airspace and its hockey and soccer teams
ejected from international leagues as
jackson proskow reports if putin's goal
was to divide the west he has done the
exact opposite
with his country besieged by russia
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
took another swipe at vladimir putin
formerly requesting membership in the eu
our goal is to be with all europeans and
most importantly to be equal he said
russia's attempt to shatter ukraine has
instead solidified international support
nato and eu members have promised
military aid they've closed their
airspace to russian jets and delivered
wave after wave of sanctions the u.s
froze the assets of russia's central
bank even historically neutral
switzerland agreed to side with ukraine
if ukraine does not survive we cannot be
surprised if democracy fails next at an
emergency meeting of the united nations
the sudden collapse of the post-cold war
era weighed heavily we are today at a
crucial and historical moment too many
times in the past the international
community has been blind
or too slow in front of unfolding
tragedies
vladimir putin called the west's
coordinated efforts an empire of lies
yet moscow's isolation only grows deeper
the u.s says it will expel a dozen
russian diplomats to the u.n it accuses
of espionage in a further blow turkey
limited naval access to the black sea
against that backdrop the pentagon says
there is currently no mechanism for
avoiding an accidental conflict between
nuclear superpowers and that has put
limits on nato's resolve for now the
alliance has no plans to establish or
enforce a no-fly zone over ukraine
donna okay jackson thank you
it is never too late to stop
it's never too late to make a turn to
diplomacy
to dialogue
and to negotiation
that is bob ray canada's ambassador to
the u.n he warned today against giving
in to putin's threats to use nuclear
weapons canada is sending a third
shipment of lethal weapons to ukraine's
army our chief political correspondent
david aiken is in ottawa with the
details on that
well donna the canadian government has
been under pressure to do much more to
support ukraine and today it responded
to one key request agreeing to send more
weapons today we are announcing that we
will be supplying ukraine with anti-tank
weapons systems and upgraded ammunition
those weapons include 125 anti-tank guns
together with 2 000 rockets all coming
from existing inventory held by the
canadian armed forces and to be
delivered as quickly as possible
that announcement was made as a canadian
air force c-130 transport plane was on
route to eastern europe with some of the
25 million dollars in non-lethal
military aid ottawa promised on sunday
things like body armor and night vision
goggles prime minister justin trudeau
also joined a teleconference monday
morning with u.s president joe biden and
other world leaders where they
considered their response to vladimir
putin's decision over the weekend to
raise the alert level on russia's
nuclear forces trudeau said allies are
resolved to continue with their course
we will not
be backing down on the economic measures
and sanctions that we have put forward
canada also announced a ban on all
imports of russian crude oil that's more
a symbolic gesture as canada has not
imported any russian crude since late
2019 but canada has not yet announced a
ban on imports of refined russian
petroleum donna david aiken in ottawa
thank you and today canada's deputy
prime minister had this message for the
russian people
a few brave russian officials have
spoken out against putin's barbaric war
we encourage all russians to oppose this
war
silence is complicity
and following orders is not an excuse
and so when it comes to canada's
response everything is on the table
sanctions are hitting russia's economy
hard at one point the ruble its currency
fell more than 43 percent against the
u.s dollar today it did recover some
ground after russia's central bank hiked
its key interest rate to 20 percent more
than double what it was yesterday to
help shore up the ruble and hold back a
run on banks the sanctions are an
unprecedented effort designed to choke
the economy and force putin's hand
though as ann gaviola reports they'll
have an impact on the rest of the world
too
as russian troops meet resistance on the
ground in ukraine financial blows are
raining down on its economy the country
has in many ways become the financial
pariah of the western world cut off from
the swift global financial network as
they're being overnight
taken out of the modern digital 21st
century financial economy
monday wall street shunned russia too as
the new york stock exchange and the
nasdaq halted trading of russian
companies russia's economy in freefall
its biggest bank on the brink of failure
if we do see a collapse it may harm
people in russia but it is very unlikely
to take down or harm the global
financial system russia's economy is in
a tailspin but sanctions aren't as
harmful as they could be because they
don't take aim at russian energy exports
which make up a third of its gdp oil and
natural gas from russia that europe
depends on we may be doing a lot of
damage to the population and the russian
economy but it is not necessarily
getting straight to the leader at the
top
analysts say a lot hangs on the success
of the sanctions which target putin
russian oligarchs and their money yachts
and reputation well they have 6000
nuclear warheads and that changes
everything
this economic battle an important one
against an emboldened nuclear power
and the financial assault on russia has
kicked into a higher gear and household
budgets across canada won't escape what
should people brace for here yeah
there's going to be ripple effects for
sure let's start things off with
portfolios people have probably noticed
the sell-off today expect more stock
market volatility going forward as for
household budgets more inflation on top
of the inflation that we're already
dealing with you may have noticed if
you've filled up over the weekend prices
at the pumps moving higher and i'm told
by gas analysts that's just the tip of
the iceberg depending on how long this
drags on higher prices and more delays
as well for food items and things that
have been touched by supply chain
disruptions including items that contain
microchips from smart fridges to cars to
tech devices
so what does all of this extra
inflationary pressure mean for the bank
of canada is what a lot of people are
wondering the expectation for bank of
canada's rate announcement on wednesday
is still a modest one 25 basis points
but what all of this could mean is that
the bank of canada may be forced to hold
rates lower for longer donna lots to
watch for ann gaviola in toronto thanks
two orphaned children commended coming
up their brave actions as a gunman went
on a rampage in nova scotia two years
ago
[Music]
there are new revelations from the
commission investigating the massacre of
22 people in nova scotia nearly two
years ago new evidence suggests the rcmp
knew more than they admitted about the
gunman who was disguised as a police
officer and an inquiry lawyer also
praised two children for their poise
while speaking to a 9-1-1 operator as
they hid from the man who murdered their
parents
at one point the kids expressed concern
for elderly members of porto pick given
the fires
and expressed concern for officer safety
i guess it's not my place to say what i
think about the kids
but
the commission hopes to have a final
report by november
ahead the un's warning on climate change
[Music]
a bleak warning today about the climate
crisis the u.n secretary general calls
the latest findings from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change and atlas of human suffering
heather urex west explains
this year in canada it was the people of
litton british columbia who watched
their homes burn the farmers of the
sumas prairie who lost animals and
livelihoods to floods and
drought-stricken cattle farmers in
manitoba forced to sell herds they could
no longer feed so people on the planet
are getting clobbered by climate change
nearly half of humanity is living in the
danger zone the latest report from the
un's intergovernmental panel on climate
change warns climate is already having a
staggering impact on human health more
than 3 billion people globally that's
more than 40 percent are considered
highly vulnerable to the impacts of
climate change and 15 times more likely
to die from extreme weather events what
the report really clearly shows is that
quite frankly right now we're not on
track to being resilient to climate
change in the future
and the window for action is rapidly
closing because while it still may be
possible to adapt to future heat waves
fires and floods if the global climate
is allowed to warm beyond 1.5 degrees
celsius any hope of building resiliency
could disappear the facts are undeniable
these abdication of leadership is
criminal
the world's biggest polluters are guilty
of arson on our only home
fueled by canada's status as the fifth
largest producer of the world's oil and
gas if climate change were a car crash
canada is in the driving the driver's
seat we must continue to cut our
missions and build resiliency through
our society but while ottawa points to
its carbon tax and commitments to
emissions reductions so far canada's
greenhouse gas emissions have only
continued to rise heather york's west
global news calgary
next the remarkable leadership of
ukraine's president
there's an update on the 13 ukrainian
border guards on a tiny island in the
black sea
who were reported to have refused to
surrender they told a russian warship to
go f yourself and all communication was
lost ukraine's president said they died
heroically russia denied they'd been
killed and today that was confirmed by
the ukrainians
ukraine's navy now says russia took them
captive after they ran out of supplies
to defend the island they are being held
as prisoners of war
well there's a saying that the truth is
the first casualty of war and much will
be learned after this conflict is over
what's clear already though is the role
of ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
trained as a lawyer but built a career
as a comedian and actor now he's playing
a pivotal role in the future of his
country zielinski was elected in 2019
during his inaugural address that year
he said this
don't hang my portrait in your offices a
president is not an icon nor an idol he
said put photographs of your children
there instead and before making any
decision
look them in the eyes
redmond shannon on the fierce resolve
and bravery of ukraine's president
president
the president is here we are all here
the words of vladimir zelinski on nice
two of the invasion cutting through
rumors that he had fled with a simple
selfie video from the streets of kiev as
russian forces approached the u.s
offered him support to escape zielinski
reportedly rejected it with these now
famous words i need ammunition not a
ride
history is full of leaders who run when
the odds are against them zielinski's
videos have instead reassured and
inspired his people as ukrainians dig in
and defy the russian army
[Music]
every citizen is president he says and a
warrior his leadership and courage
earning respect around the world he is
the embodiment of the courage of
ukrainian people
it was only three years ago zielinski
was a tv president playing for laughs as
a teacher who accidentally becomes
leader ukrainians who were fed up with
his pro-russian predecessor and with
corruption voted him in for real
a multi-talented comedian and actor with
a law degree from a russian-speaking
jewish family he won ukraine's dancing
with the stars
and even voiced the ukrainian version of
paddington it's interesting that the
paddington bear is fighting a big bear
ukrainian political analyst darisia
lucevic says zielinski has made mistakes
but his conviction is what matters now
at the time of existential threat like
ukraine is facing today they're all all
united across all languages political
parties communities you have absolute
cohesion
says the enemy has marked him as number
one target but he has refused to yield
and rallied global support in the
process the funny man who's proving to
be nobody's fool redmond shannon global
news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen people around
the world continue to rally around
ukraine from ottawa's peace tower to
sydney's opera house buildings and
monuments are bathed in the color of
ukraine's flag
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye bye
you